a little boosie he's been on the pod you
know that and he had a
he had a little speech he gave about
homosexuality being pushed
he said how y'all trying to force this
this gay stuff on the world
it's safe how y'all trying to ban
artists
y'all sad bro it's sad bro
you know in 10 years it ain't gonna be
normal for a kid to be straight
you know it's sad bro y'all trying to
force it on
on on these kids bro you know
you pushing it on the artist push it on
all the biggest artists you know why
cause the kids love those artists
you're attacking these kids the kids
love these artists so we're gonna make
all of them promote this [ __ ] we're
gonna make all them promoted
and who gonna follow the kids
it's sad bro
it's sad bro little boosie speaking out
one thing i love about laboose he's
always a
he's always willing to share what his
real thoughts are
you know and it's something i i struggle
to do man i think a lot of us struggle
to do that in today's
society with a fear of retaliation
you know and most of my fear of
retaliation
you know comes sometimes from
uh you know just that i won't be able to
have opportunities on certain platforms
i'll be d platformed it's pretty
it's pretty scary you know that
here we are you know
america like uh how it even got started
people wanted to think their own way
and think something that was against the
norm and say stuff that was against the
norm so they left
in a boat but now there's no new place
to go to
um
there's no you can't just get in a boat
and go to a new america
canada's not even letting people in
right now they're still dealing with the
first covert or whatever i don't know
what they're doing
you know and i wish somebody would go
help them out because they're you know i
get so many dms from people in canada
like jesus christ come help us out
you know they found five people with
covid
in a snow bank somewhere up near
you know up in saskatchewan and so now
the rest of us
can't go see our grandparents for
another year
but lobuci look man they definitely
it feels like there is a lot of times an
agenda
this bigger picture agenda you know
like being straight is definitely
feels like it's
like it is frowned upon
or it is it's not right
um i i
agree in all in some of the sense that a
lot of times they want to create a lot
of uncertainty and kids
and that's who who consumes a lot of
stuff and who really believes a lot of
things that they see through media
you know you got eight-year-old children
now saying that they're
they may be gay or or they are gay and
you're like well
you might be but i wouldn't it might be
a little early to call the horse race
and it's wild man the media's wild on
all fronts
you know i think anyway the media has
just gotten out of control
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one